je vais t'appeler jeanine jeanine oui
[Applaudissements]
on
dirait une tente à juan
g christ et le retour de l'accès leur
aide à la prise hier l'armée sous la
peau c'est un petit garçon qui couvre à
la raison il va vers sa mère lui dit
maman maman le frigo est tombée à dix
bals dira-t-on pen dit je peux pas et
n'est sous le frigo
c'est pire c'est fou ce genre à verse
ainsi j'ai pas à crédit
mais je te dis parce qu'on dirait une
vraie elle le perd quelqu'un qu'on
connaît à chaque fois c'est pas ta pas
des têtes ont dit non à une période où l
on l'a connu en avait amassé une
personne est à la maison hier tu vois
jean-luc que tu es comme tu veux un truc
parce que je sais que t'as pas et
franchement j'ai pas une tête à peru
alors ne restez pas sur le rythme et
jean-luc vous allez voir à chaque fois
créer une perruque aussi je sais que
c'est un fou rire mais il a l'air de se
taper vas-y mon attention
richard richard houis
[Applaudissements]
jean-luc à chaque fois qu une perruque
ne restez pas sur benghazi et alors
billy beli beli moder cliniques comme ça
à tout à éviter aussi
sa lutte jean-luc oui
papa six matches
truqués ce tabou des rideaux paye
d'opéra n'y avait pas de bouder bout des
temps modernes oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]